[Music]  before a world of Heroes  and villains  one power  ruled it all  Black Adam  he's been asleep for 5 000 years  I got him we're here to negotiate your  peaceful surrender I'm not peaceful  nor do I Surrender  hours  are not a gift  but a curse  born out of rage you have two choices  you can be the destroyer of this world  or you can be  a savior  [Applause]  Black Adam  we're here to negotiate your peaceful  surrender I'm not peaceful  nor do I Surrender it's his darkness  that lets him do what Heroes cannot the  battle you're meant to fight is upon us  there's no one on this planet that can  stop me  it's like Adam really PG-13 October 21st  [Music]  thank you